- It was a sad sad day when the countess
finally kicked the bucket.
But the wealthy woman left a will.
In her will she left all her money
to her three grandchildren.
Despite the fact that they
were kinda spoiled brats.
The last line of the will stated that she
had one final thing to give away, a ruby,
the size of a gosh darn walnut.
Holy hoo-haw, I want that
walnut, said the oldest.
However, the old woman only gave one clue
as to where that juicy
ruby might be located.
The ruby lies in a cylinder,
surrounded by a thousand squares.
After a long period of
intense and fruitless thought,
the youngest grandchild
said, I know where it is.
She ran off and two minutes later
returned with that juicy ruby.
Where was it hidden?
- The (bleep) (laughter).
- I don't know.
- First of all, why is grandma
leaving riddles in her will?
Ain't nobody got time for this.
- This is really doin' my head in.
- Do I get more clues, no?
- Can't be her grave, it can't be--
- What is this again (laughs)?
- Maybe it's like a haunted house,
maybe it's like in a
fun house or something.
Now I'm goin' all over the place.
- A taleidoscope?
Okay.
- It's square, are you
talking about how they'll
call people squares, like they're not hip.
- Inside a television, inside her house.
- I don't know, I have
no idea, yeah I give up.
- [Voiceover] So where was the ruby?
It was hidden in a roll of toilet paper.
A cylinder surrounded
by a thousand squares.
Give or take a few.
- Oh my God, I'm so angry, I'm so angry.
- This is what I was
thinking, uhh, this sucks!
- It's gonna be something
really simple, isn't it?
- Are you (bleep) serious?
What the (bleep) is this?
Are you...oh my God, a thousand mm, okay.
(jazzy music)